bonjour à tous et bienvenue chez Google
on se retrouve aujourd'hui ici en
partenariat avec Xiaomi pour faire vivre
une aventure incroyable à 12 Xiaomi fun
alors il pense venir faire une visite
des locaux de Google ce qui est pas
complètement faux mais surtout le
réserver une énorme surprise une journée
remplie d'aventure escape game cascade
on va se balader dans Paris pour à la
fin gagner le nouveau smartphone de
Xiaomi le Xiaomi 12 t pro qui n'est pas
encore sorti et en plus de ça le grand
gagnant viendra avec nous à Munich au
lancement mondial du smartphone rien que
ça on commence ici chez Google parce
qu'il y a une vraie synergie entre
Xiaomi et Google de l'autre côté vous
connaissez tous les services Google
qu'on peut retrouver dans les
smartphones de Xiaomi le Play Store bien
évidemment Google photos Google meet
Google Lens j'en passe des meilleurs
bonne humeur cascade aventure vous êtes
prêts c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est ici dans le showroom de Google
qu'on va cueillir les participants dans
quelques instants le temps de le
remettre en Starter Pack et on est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est quoi c'est nouveau téléphone de
Xiaomi sur dans 3 semaines nous ce qu'on
veut c'est du smile on veut du bonheur
on veut de la joie donc on va aller
chercher des smile on va faire la chasse
au smile pour gagner le Golden smile
alors je vous explique comment ça va se
passer aujourd'hui c'est très simple
d'abord vous allez jouer en équipe ceux
qui joueront ensuite pour la finale
l'équipe va être éclatée vous allez
jouer individuellement pour la première
épreuve les participants vont prendre
leur Xiaomi 12 tes pros et avec Google
Lens pour me dire scanner des panneaux
pour connaître la composition de leur
équipe
[Musique]
faut qu'il vienne chercher il y a des
indices alors je sais que c'est pas
extrêmement évident on arrive comme ça
on sait pas ce qui se passe mais bon on
y va en boss allez on bosse
[Musique]
pour la deuxième épreuve ils vont devoir
deviner où est leur prochaine
destination alors du coup on fait partie
de l'équipe jaune si j'ai bien compris
et on doit faire 700 pas pour avoir le
prochain indice
[Musique]
faut transformer
les équipes sont actuellement dans leur
van je vais les appeler à tour de rôle
pour leur poser des questions pour leur
faire gagner des smileys bonus de votre
groupe je fais la force je suis en
mariage célébré que suis-je dans l'Union
si tu plais à quelqu'un tu m'auras que
suis-je une touche bon les trois équipes
sont plutôt pas trop mal débrouillées
pour l'instant rien n'est joué le défi
continue et on ne sait toujours pas qui
va gagner
[Musique]
épreuve suivante on est aux Invalides à
Paris il y a les différentes équipes qui
vont arriver à tour de rôle elles vont
devoir deviner avec les mouvements que
je fais la combinaison du cadenas pour
ouvrir et pouvoir continuer l'aventure
mais il y a des positions
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est bon
il semblerait que l'équipe verte soit un
peu en avance mais les autres sont pas
loin derrière et à mon avis tout va
jouer sur la dernière ligne droite
il va falloir un mot de passe
[Musique]
on va faire un blind test c'est un point
pour le titre et l'artiste
[Musique]
un point si vous mettez l'ambiance
il y a peut-être un point bonus si vous
faites autre chose pour mettre
l'ambiance
[Musique]
les équipes arrivent maintenant au siège
de Xiaomi France où ils vont devoir
résoudre différentes énigmes
bleu et rouge
[Musique]
un chronomètre de 30 minutes pas plus il
va être enclenché c'est 30 minutes vont
vous permettre de réaliser un maximum de
monde des vies allez ciao et bon courage
à tous
[Musique]
alors du coup là on est sur l'épreuve
numéro 7 défis en folie voilà ça va être
trop bien et on est motivé les
participants vont réaliser certains
défis de leur choix pour gagner des
smileys bonus le tout dans la joie et la
bonne humeur quelle équipe en sortira
vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la maison connectée
Xiaomi les trois équipes vont bientôt
arriver et on va pouvoir savoir enfin
quelle équipe va aller en finale
[Musique]
vous êtes de retour ça y est bon alors
là on a fini la partie des épreuves en
groupe le groupe qui a gagné va
continuer on épreuve individuelle alors
on va pas y aller par 36000 côtés
l'équipe qui a gagné c'est l'équipe
jaune donc on applaudit jaune un grand
merci à tous et puis on va continuer
pour la grande phase finale avec trois
épreuves merci à vous
maintenant qu'on connaît nos quatre
finalistes il va y avoir trois épreuves
pour les départager première épreuve les
cartes les candidats vont devoir
mémoriser les 10 cartes les reconstituer
de leur côté ça donnera un avantage non
négligeable dans la cuisine
[Musique]
excellent bravo
les quatre candidats vont passer au
fourneau ils ont différents ingrédients
des carottes des pommes de terre et même
des macaronis ils vont me dire cuisiner
ici directement sur leur frayeur alors
attention je serai juge faut que ça me
plaise faut que ce soit beau faut que ce
soit bon puis je vais essayer de les
déstabiliser leur temps plein de pièges
les ingrédients se trouvent au fond
là-bas vous pouvez venir prendre les
ingrédients que vous voulez 5
ingrédients maximum comme tu arrives les
premiers tu as un avantage tu choisis
tes 5 ingrédients mais tu vas choisir
l'ingrédient de ton petit camarade juste
après tu lui mets l'ingrédient que tu
veux voilà donc tu peux mettre handicap
tu peux lui mettre du Nutella du miel ce
que tu veux et la même chose toi tu
choisis ensuite quatre ingrédients pour
toi et un ingrédient
[Musique]
en mode on dégénéré on se passe des
choses quoi quel était la douceur
préférée de Marie-Antoinette la première
c'est les clés au chocolat la deuxième
le macaron la troisième le pain au
chocolat
[Musique]
là tu me fais le soleil les Russes
mettaient quelque chose de particulier
dans leur bouteille de lait pour les
conserver ah du sel B une grenouille
c'est un type de champignon mais on dira
pas lequel une grenouille je te
soupçonne de boire des choses bizarres
quand même
[Musique]
visuellement il y a un vrai travail mais
un
très bien réussi bravo c'est très joli
j'ai voyagé je suis un peu Maldives je
suis à la cool ça va bien donc bravo à
toi
j'adore les framboises effectivement je
me dis bon les framboises à côté de ma
carotte patate douce c'est un truc un
peu bizarre mais c'est joli il y a de
l'idée ça j'adore ça manque un peu de
cuisson mais un peu trop tank bravo à
toi
là je me sens un peu au bord de la
Méditerranée et là où est-ce que tu as
voulu m'emmener
le petit effort c'est bien qu'on peut un
peu dire bravo
bravo et merci à tous vous m'avez
presque régalé alors les résultats sont
sans appel on a un vainqueur on a un
premier un deuxième un troisième mais on
a un dernier alors je vous explique le
principe la personne qui arrivera
dernière ici elle va nous quitter tout
de suite je donne dans l'ordre d'arrivée
premier c'est Kevin on a un petit 12 65
félicitations le deuxième et bien c'est
Sofiane avec un petit 12 et bien c'est
Natacha qui arrivait troisième et qui va
continuer l'aventure et puis quitte Sada
écoute voilà bon félicitations à vous
quatre vous avez très très bien bossé
maintenant on va enchaîner tout de suite
avec la dernière épreuve pour enfin
gagner et bien ce nouveau Xiaomi 12 t
pro et devenir avec moi Munich dernière
épreuve et pas des moindres chaque
candidat va venir chercher dans une zone
qui lui est propre différents indices
pour récupérer la combinaison du coffre
et trouver enfin le Golden smiley
[Musique]
félicitations bravo Sofiane bon alors ne
soyez pas déçu vous êtes quand même les
finalistes vous repartez comme avec un
cadeau cette jolie trottinette c'est une
trottinette de Xiaomi c'est la Xiaomi
électrique scooter 3 light félicitations
à vous à vous d'être arrivé juste là
encore félicitations à Sofiane et puis
bravo à tous les participants alors il
faut savoir que tous ceux qui ont perdu
repart quand même avec un smartphone
merci un Xiaomi de nous avoir permis de
réaliser cette vidéo c'est très très
chouette merci également à Google qui
était là on a utilisé tous les services
Google on s'est bien amusé on s'est
baladé dans Paris c'est une super
expérience merci également à vous
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo et puis
dites-nous tout ce que vous en pensez
juste en bas en commentaire et n'oubliez
pas on s'abonne la cloche je vous
embrasse à bientôt salut tout le monde à
bientôt Ciao